[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER HEIDEN:
So last time, we
discussed the TCA cycle.
And that allows us to
then, you know, say
how we can take glucose and
completely oxidize those six
glucose carbons into CO2.
And you know, of course,
glycolysis converts glucose
into two pyruvate.
Pyruvate has two carbons, and
then pyruvate dehydrogenase
can release the first
of those carbons as CO2.
It generates an acetyl CoA.
That acetyl CoA then
enters the TCA cycle,
and two other CO2s
are released--
one of the isocitrate
dehydrogenase
step, one of the alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
step.
Now, we discussed that
the TCA cycle is useful
because it allows you
to oxidize anything that
can be turned into
acetyl CoA into CO2,
and that includes
fatty acids, which
we will spend a lot of
time talking about today.
Now, the TCA cycle, as I
mentioned, just by review,
is also very useful as a
way to make stuff-- lots
of useful intermediates.
But we discussed last time
if we're going to do that--
that is, because it
functions as a cycle--
if we remove stuff
from the cycle,
something has to be added back
in-- so-called anaplerosis--
in order to have it continue
to function as a cycle.
Now, you'll note-- we
weren't explicit about this,
but this is oxidation.
Remember, carbon oxidation
is generally favorable.
So delta G of this
will be less than 0.
However, unlike
glycolysis, where
we discussed that most of
the harnessing of energy--
that is, the favorable oxidation
of glucose to pyruvate--
was captured to directly keep an
ATP/ADP ratio high in the cell,
you can see that most of the
energy output of the TCA cycle
isn't actually direct
synthesis of ATP or GTP.
Instead, what we have is
we have most of that energy
as being captured and charging
up a ratio of NADH to NAD,
or FADH2 to FAD.
And we'll see over the
next several lectures
how we can harness electron
transfer from those molecules
to oxygen to make ATP, as
well as do some other work.
But before we get
to that, I want
to first focus a
bit on fat, which,
of course, is the most reduced
carbon biomolecule in the cell.
And so that's chains of
fully reduced carbon.
And of course, this is the
most chemically dense way
to store energy--
as carbon.
Intuitively, you know this,
because what's oil and gas?
It's chains of
reduced hydrocarbons.
Of course, those
are better fuels
than wood, which are,
as we saw before,
based on carbohydrate
alcohol carbons.
You also know
intuitively that fat
has more calories than sugar--
exactly same ideas.
And so I want to
start by discussing
what biological fat
is, and then that
will lead into a
discussion about how
we can oxidize the fat,
also, as a way to get energy.
Now, most biological
fat is packaged
into molecules called lipids.
And so I want to make
clear that lipids are not
the same thing as fat.
More correctly, a lipid contains
fat-- or more precisely,
something called a fatty acid.
And so what is a fatty acid?
Well, it's this fully
saturated hydrocarbon
with a carboxylic
acid on the end.
And so we have a
carboxylic acid followed
by some chain of fully
saturated hydrocarbons.
So it differs from
oil and gasoline
in that it has this carboxylic
acid handle, if you will,
on the end that basically allows
biology to build and break down
these fatty acids.
Now, most biological fatty acids
have even numbers of carbons.
And it turns out that that's
a consequence of the fact
that it's built and broken
down into these two carbon
acetyl CoA units.
And the most common lengths--
that is, how long
these chains are.
So in biology, they can vary
anywhere from 4 to 36 carbons
long.
But the most common ones
are 12 to 24 carbons,
with 16 carbons and 18 carbons
being by far the most abundant
in cells.
Now, it's worth
mentioning what some
of the names of these
more common ones are,
because you'll see them.
And so the fully saturated
16 carbon fatty acid--
so 16 carbon total.
14, 15, 16, including
the carboxylic acid.
This is referred
to as palmitate.
Or it's drawn in the
acid form, palmitic acid.
And the systematic name for
this is hexadecanoic acid.
The other common one,
the 18 carbon version--
so same molecule, but
two carbons longer.
That's referred to as
stearate, or stearic acid,
if drawn in the acid form.
Or the systematic name
would be octadecanoic acid.
Now, oftentimes
things like palmitate
can also be drawn like this.
So there's 16 carbons.
Another way to draw palmitate.
And you'll note that
palmitate as well as stearate
here are fully saturated.
What do I mean by saturated?
I mean fully saturated
by electrons.
There's no way to reduce
this molecule further,
unless, of course, we reduce
the carboxylic acid on the end.
And so palmitate
would be the most
saturated 16 carbon fatty acid.
Stearate is the most saturated
18 carbon fatty acid.
Now, if I add a double bond
to one of these molecules,
that's an oxidation.
So just like when we
added a double bond
to succinate to make
fumarate in the TCA cycle.
I showed that last time.
That's an oxidation reaction.
And so an unsaturated
fatty acid is
a fatty acid that is no longer
fully saturated with electrons.
That means it is
not fully reduced.
And so, remember, you store
energy as reduced carbon.
And so an unsaturated fatty
acid stores less energy
than a saturated fatty
acid because it's
more oxidized than the
saturated fatty acid.
And so just as a couple
examples here-- so here's
the example of a 16-carbon
unsaturated fatty acid.
So I introduce a double bond.
I'll draw it in
the acid form here.
And so here you got 5,
6, 7, 8 plus 7 is 15--
16 carbons total,
one double bond.
This is all middle oleic acid,
more systematically named
hexadecene acid.
And the 18-carbon version
would be as follows.
So I added two extra carbons
on this end of the molecule.
This is oleic acid,
or octadecanoic acid.
Now, note I put a
double bond in here.
You'll remember from
organic chemistry
that double bonds can exist
in a trans or a cis form.
And so if it's trans,
it would be like this.
If it's cis, the
double bond would be
like that in the carbon chain.
And so just to show
you here on the models
that this can matter, so here
is a double bonded carbon.
And so these two red guys
are cis to each other.
And this purple
is trans to that.
Now, if I put this onto
a fatty acid chain,
you can see that there's
a big difference there.
So if I add the
double bond in here
and it's continued the
chain here on a trans bond,
it's a relatively
straight molecule,
whereas if I go
here in a cis bond,
I now introduce a kink
into the alkyl chain.
So biological fatty
acids are always cis.
And this is
structurally important
because it actually creates
this kink in fatty acids
that are not fully saturated.
Now, obviously, as
you might guess,
the number of double
bonds and the locations
of the double bonds will change
the structure and therefore
the properties of
the fatty acids.
And so we need a
nomenclature that
allows us to describe
what's going on here.
And so the simplest
nomenclature is
as follows, where we basically
have the number of carbons
and the fatty acids,
say 18, followed
by the number of double bonds.
So an 18:1 fatty acid,
that's oleic acid--
so 18 carbons long,
one double bond--
18:0 would be steric acid--
18 carbons long, zero double
bonds; 16:0, palmitate--
palmitic acid--
16 carbons long,
zero double bonds.
So if we have one double
bond, oftentimes this
is referred to as a MUFA, or
monounsaturated fatty acid.
And, of course, if I
have many double bonds--
more than one-- that's a PUFA,
or a polyunsaturated fatty
acid--
probably heard those terms.
So what's an example of a
polyunsaturated fatty acid?
Well, a common one is an 18:2
polyunsaturated fatty acids--
18 carbons, two double bonds.
The common biological one
is called linoleic acid--
and CH3-- and so 1, 2 double
bonds, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
17, 18 carbons total, 18:2
fatty acid, linoleic acid--
formal name is
octadecadiene oleic acid.
If I make it more unsaturated--
so 18:3-- that is linolenic
acid, or octadecatrienoic acid.
And if I painfully draw
out the entire thing--
so we've got 1, 2, 3, double
bonds, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 17, 18 carbons total--
18:3 polyunsaturated fatty acid
with three double bonds in it.
In all of these cases,
all of those double bonds
are cis double bonds.
And you'll also notice
that the spacing of them
is not entirely random
either, at least as I drew it.
The first of all is
that these are not
conjugated double
bonds, so you see
that there's a carbon in all
cases between the double bond.
And also, you'll notice that
most of the double bonds are
actually started, if you
count from this end--
from the acid end--
this would be carbon 9 and
10-- so 1 plus 7 is 8, 9, 10.
Each of them-- the first
double bond I put in
is between carbons 9 and
10 going in this direction.
And that's a consequence
of the conserved enzymes
that introduced these double
bonds into the molecule.
Now, obviously this
spacing matters.
And so we need a way
in the nomenclature
in order to denote that.
That is where exactly the
double bonds are located.
And there are sort of two ways.
We can count we can
count from one end.
Or, we can count
from the other end.
Now, the most systematic way--
correct way now is to count
from the carboxylic acid end.
So very similar to sugars,
we counted carbon 1 of sugars
to be the one that was closest
to the end of the molecule
where the carbonyl was located.
So same thing in
fatty acid, so this
would be carbon 1 count
in that direction.
And so the nomenclature would
be then to put it in a delta 9,
would be a double bond between
the 9th and 10th carbon
counting from the
carboxylic acid.
And so the 18:2 fatty acid
I drew here, linoleic acid,
would more precisely be
18:2, delta 9, delta 12.
That's because it's carbon
9, 10, 11, 12-- so carbon 9
and 10 and 12 and 13.
Linolenic acid--
18:3, delta 9 12, 15--
so 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15 to say
where the double bonds are
in the polyunsaturated fatty
acids.
As you can see, most
polyunsaturated fatty acids
is a consequence that
they're not conjugated.
You'll see that the double bonds
are placed every three carbons.
Now, this three carbon spacing
is maintained even in the--
often in biology, even in the
exceptions, where the first one
is not between carbon 9 and 10.
And so a classic
example of that is
the polyunsaturated fatty
acid arachidonic acid,
which is a 20 carbine fatty
acid with four double bonds
at carbons 5, 8, 11, and 14.
So arachidonic acid, you
may have heard in the past,
is a key signaling fatty acid.
It's mobilized and
used to generate
some inflammatory mediators.
It's the enzyme that
acts on this to generate
the inflammatory mediators--
is the target of very common
drugs, like aspirin or other
nonsteroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs--
ibuprofen, et cetera.
And this molecule,
drawing it like this,
should fully describe to
you what it would look like.
Now, there's also an
older nomenclature
that numbers fatty
acids to name them
and where the double
bonds are located--
not from the carbonyl side,
but from the other end
of the molecule.
And I mentioned
this nomenclature
because it's still used quite
often in popular culture.
And so to do this,
it's basically--
refers to this, I guess,
as the alpha carbon.
So counting in Greek,
going this direction,
the final carbon in
the fatty acid, omega--
the last letter
the Greek alphabet.
And so if you count
from the other end,
we could also give this
different nomenclature.
And so in this case, our
18:3 linolenic acid, 18:3,
delta 9, 12, 15, we could also
say is 18:3, omega 3, 6, 9.
So now we're counting
from this end--
1, 2, 3, first double
the bond, 4, 5, 6,
next double bond, 7,
8, 9, next double bond.
And so thus, 18:1, by
this nomenclature--
18:1, delta 9, would
be the same as 18:1,
omega 9 because it's obviously
meeting in the middle.
But if we did 18:1, delta 12,
that would be 18:1, omega 6.
18:1, delta 15 would
be 18:1, omega 3.
And so I mention
this because you'll
hear about so-called
omega 3 fatty acids.
The major omega 3 fatty acid
that they're talking about
is linolenic acid.
And it's an omega 3 fatty acid
using the nomenclature counting
from the other side.
Or, you could also say
it's 18:3, delta 9, 12, 15.
Now, I want to mention one
of the reasons you hear about
omega 3 fatty acids
is that, in general,
there are fatty acids such as
those that humans cannot make.
And so we have to get
those from the diet.
And so this is the concept
called essential fatty acids.
And so somewhat like
vitamins, there's
things out there
that our physiology
uses that we have to get
from other organisms making.
And therefore, we
have to eat them.
And so if you hear this
term essential fatty acid,
it's basically referring
to specific fatty acids
where we lack the enzymes to
place all the double bonds
to be in the place where
it's useful for some aspect
of our biology.
Now, lots of nomenclature here--
the reason I discuss this is
because this diversity of chain
length and double bonds creates
different properties and nature
uses these diverse chemical
properties of the fatty acids--
that is, different links
and different degrees
of unsaturation or saturation
positions of the double bonds--
to take advantage
of those properties
to do different
things in biology.
And so a lot of this has to do--
a lot of why fatty acids are
useful is that they are
not soluble in water
or poorly soluble in water.
You know this just from
the common experience
of making salad dressing.
And so you mix the oil in the
vinegar in the salad dressing,
and so the oil is largely
made out of fatty acids,
made out of lipids.
And those fatty acids are not
soluble in the vinegar part,
the water part of the molecule.
Now, the fatty acid themselves--
the chain length and the
number of double bonds
will affect other
properties, such as
the melting temperature.
So in general, the melting
temperature of a fatty acid
will decrease with
shorter chain length
and decrease with more
unsaturation-- so more double
bonds.
So the more double
bonds I put in
and the shorter it is, the
lower the melting temperature.
And so you guys know this,
from just cooking experience,
to be the case.
And so animal fatty acids
tend to be more saturated.
And because they're
more saturated,
they have a higher
melting temperature.
And so they're solids
at room temperature.
So think about it--
animal fat, butter, lard--
these things are solid
at room temperature.
So plant fatty acids--
they tend to be more
unsaturated fatty acids.
And they're liquids
at room temperature.
And you know this because
cooking oil made from plants
is typically a liquid
at room temperature.
Now, you might be
aware that olive oil
has a lot of monounsaturated
fatty acids, a lot of MUFAs.
Olive oil, unlike
other plant oils,
which are more
polyunsaturated fatty acids--
if you put those in
the refrigerator,
the olive oil will
tend to form a solid,
whereas your canola
oil will not.
And that's a
consequence of the fact
that the more unsaturated
fatty acids are,
the lower the
melting temperature.
And so the more
likely it is to be
a liquid or a solid in
the fridge or at room
temperature across these
different fatty acids.
To show here on
the slide, here's
just something I stole
from the textbook.
It basically gives
the composition
of some things you might
be aware of-- so olive oil,
butter, and beef fat.
So you can see as we go
down the spectrum here,
you have longer chain
lengths and a reduction
in the number of double bonds.
And, of course, beef fat,
if you've ever handled it,
is a much firmer solid
at room temperature
than butter, which is of course
solid at room temperature,
whereas olive oil is not.
And that follows this
with the chain length
and the double bonds
really affecting
the melting temperature
of these different fats.
Just a couple of sides
so you can better
understand your food--
and so you may have
heard about or seen
on the side of your food
packaging hydrogenated oils.
So what's a hydrogenated oil?
Well, that's basically
taking a plant
oil, which has unsaturated fatty
acids and hydrogenating it.
That is adding hydrogen.
Well, what is that?
It's not really the
hydrogen that's being added.
It's adding electrons
so it's taking it
from being a unsaturated fatty
acid to chemically making
it a saturated fatty acid.
And it's a way to
take plant oils
and make it such that it's
solid at room temperature.
An example of a hydrogenated
oil would be margarine--
plant oil that would be liquid,
reduce it chemically such
that it's fully saturated,
and now it's a solid at room
temperature.
Sure you've also heard
of so-called trans fats.
So what's a trans fat
other than something
cooked up in the
devil's kitchen?
So trans fats are
basically taking animal
fat and introducing chemically
double bonds into them such
that you have this solid
that is now a liquid at room
temperature.
Now, this is done chemically to
introduce those double bonds.
And so if you're introducing
a double bond chemically
by oxidizing the
fatty acid, you'll
get some cis and some trans.
Cis is what biology does
because it introduces them
with an enzyme.
Trans versus cis
is not controlled
when it's done chemically.
And so this leads
to these unnatural
trans fatty acids, which
lead to health issues
and are now banned
in many cities,
including here in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Last aside is-- as all of
us have probably experienced
our oils or fats going rancid--
so what is that?
So that's oxygen
oxidizing the fatty acid.
And so if you want to protect
your oil from going rancid,
the thing to do is just
keep it sealed, right?
Keep oxygen away
from it and your oil
will last a lot longer.
So that's fatty acids.
In biology, most fatty
acids aren't sitting around
by themselves.
They're esterified
to an alcohol.
And as we mentioned
in an earlier lecture,
a lipid equals a
fatty acid that's
esterified to an alcohol.
So we spent some time in
the prior lecture talking
about doing this to
make phospholipids.
And that's an example of a
lipid-- fatty acids esterified
to make this phospholipid,
which gave us
both a polar and a
nonpolar end and allowed
us to create membranes.
And so lipids have lots of
important functions in cells.
And so there's the
barrier function, which
is basically membranes,
things like phospholipids
we talked about last time.
There's also signaling
functions of lipids.
So I mentioned
arachidonic acid earlier.
You'll certainly encounter
signaling functions
of lipids in other courses.
And then the last
one, which is really
the reason why we
talk about it now,
is lipids are great
for energy storage
because it's the most
reduced carbons, so the most
dense way to store
energy as reduced carbon.
So the simplest
lipid and the one
used for energy
storage is referred
to as a triacylglyceride,
often abbreviated as a TAG--
triacylglyceride.
And we can see now how we
can make a triacylglyceride
as well as how it relates to
other pathways in metabolism
that we've encountered.
And so here's our old
friend from glycolysis.
Hopefully you
recognize this molecule
as the phosphorylated
triose dihydroxyacetone
phosphate, also an
intermediate in glycolysis.
And so if we reduce this
ketone to the alcohol--
so two electrons from NADH.
Reduce that ketone, that will
oxidize the NADH to NAD+.
If we also remove the
phosphate, now what do we have?
Now we have the alcohol.
And this molecule is glycerol.
And so now this glycerol,
as we talked about before,
we can take three fatty
acids, esterify them
to each of those alcohols.
And now we have a
glycerol molecule
with three fatty acids
esterified to the alcohols
on the glycerol.
This is a triacylglyceride.
Now, of course triacylglycerides
are not soluble in water.
And so when we make these
in cells for energy storage,
they're stored as
so-called lipid droplets.
And so if you look here at
the slide, here's an example.
This up here is an
adipocyte from an animal.
This down here, I
think, is a plant cell.
And so in both cases, you
have these large droplets
that would be basically
droplets of triacylglycerides
that basically form as a way
for long-term energy storage.
And so while we think
of, at least as people,
our adipocytes, our fat cells,
as storing our fat, they do.
But they're really
specialized cell types
that have these
giant lipid droplets,
whereas many cells actually
have much smaller lipid
droplets as a way to
store triacylglycerides
as a way to store energy
as reduced carbon.
I also want to say
that if you look
at this, unlike the
phospholipids that we described
earlier as ways to
build membranes,
these don't have
a charge on them.
And so they're
sometimes referred to
as so-called neutral lipids.
And it's really
this neutral lipids
that allow them to clump
together in these oil
particles, if you will-- these
lipid droplets in cells that
are good for energy storage.
Now, why specifically
are neutral
lipids good for energy storage?
Well, really
chemically dense way
to store energy, the
most reduced carbon.
And by forming these
droplets, not unlike the oil
in your salad dressing, another
neutral lipid forming droplets
within the vinegar,
this is a way
that you store reduced
carbon without having
to carry around water.
And so if we store energy
as carbohydrates, starch
or glycogen, these molecules
have to exist in water.
So you're carrying around
the starch and glycogen.
But as an animal, we're also
carrying around the water.
If we're carrying around
reduced carbon as lipids,
we can now exclude
the water from it.
And so it's much more dense.
And we can, in a
more efficient way,
carry around this
material without having
to carry the water.
And so gram for gram, fat
is a much more efficient way
to pack on calories that we
can burn later than storing
it as carbohydrate.
Fat's also nice because
it forms a nice insulator.
And so it makes sense.
As animals, we need to
survive the winter--
pack on all kinds
of calories as fat,
don't have to carry
around as water.
Just have the energy
there as reduced carbon,
and then we can
slowly release it
over the course of
the winter, as well as
use it to keep us warm, and
then build up those stores again
during the summer months when
there's more food available.
Fat, of course, has months
worth of energy packed into it,
whereas carbohydrates that we
carry around-- our glycogen--
has less than a day's
worth of energy.
So we could live off of
our fat for the winter.
We can't live off of our
glycogen for the winter.
Now, the big trade-off
here is that it's
much slower to mobilize fat.
We have to get into
these lipid droplets
and break off
little pieces of it,
get them into aqueous
water soluble pieces
to break it down.
Glycogen, of course,
is already in water,
can break it down much faster.
And so it's much slower
to mobilize the fat.
But it can be much
more efficient
in terms of what's
stored, whereas glycogen
can be mobilized a lot faster.
And that's really part
of our physiology.
You will burn your
glycogen first
when you exercise before you
start burning a lot of fat.
And I think many
have heard about that
from just reading and thinking
about what you know about
exercise physiology.
Now again, I want
to make the point
that we all know that fat
has more calories than sugar.
And the reason for
that is, to be clear,
is because it's more reduced.
And so the energy that's
released from burning fat,
just like the energy that's
released from burning sugar,
comes because the
transfer of electrons
from the reduced hydrocarbon
to oxygen is favorable.
And that is how
energy is released.
And so fat is more
reduced than sugar,
and so more electrons
to transfer, and so more
energy released
than burning sugar.
So now let's go through, in a
pathway sense, how does nature,
rather than taking gasoline
and just igniting and releasing
a lot of energy, how
does nature stepwise
break down fatty acids in a
way that energy release can
be controlled in the
same way we described it
for carbohydrates-- glycolysis
in the TSA cycle, controlled
stepwise energy release
that can be captured
to do things like make ATP.
How does the same thing work
for oxidation of fatty acids?
Well, if as organisms
we store fatty acids
in these triacylglycerides
or other neutral lipids,
the first step is we have to get
them out of the neutral lipids.
And so if we start with
a triacylglyceride,
the first step is to
use a lipase molecule.
So a lipase just
breaks that ester bond.
And so you basically
now have glycerol
plus the three fatty acids.
We're going to spend
most of our time
today discussing how you
break down the fatty acids.
However, I want to
mention, it should be clear
how you're also going to
metabolize the glycerol.
So glycerol-- we can
oxidize the glycerol.
So now if we oxidize
that alcohol,
what are we going to get?
We're going to get
dihydroxyacetone.
And then if we phosphorylate one
of the ends of that with ATP,
now we get
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And that, of course,
can go into glycolysis,
generate pyruvate,
generate acetyl-CoA,
oxidize that acetyl-CoA
in the TCA cycle,
get energy from the
glycerol part of the lipid.
So what about oxidizing
the fatty acids?
Well, the first thing
we have to talk about
to oxidize the fatty
acids is, where is this
going to occur in the cell?
And so lipid droplets are
floating out there in the cell.
And so you mobilize these
pieces with the lipase.
Well, the glycerol now is
sitting there in the cytosol.
That can form the hydroxy
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and be burned in glycolysis,
which is in the cytosol.
But once we generate
that pyruvate-- remember
that pyruvate had to get
into the mitochondria
where we turned it
into acetyl-CoA.
So acetyl-CoA was present
in the mitochondrial matrix.
So that is here in the
matrix of the mitochondria
where the TCA cycle
happens-- remember,
glycolysis in the cytosol,
TCA cycle in the matrix.
And so that pyruvate eight
needed to get into the matrix.
So we could turn
it into acetyl-CoA.
And then that acetyl-CoA
was in the right place
to be entered into the TCA
cycle and turned into CO2.
Well, fatty acid oxidation
has the same thing.
And so if those fatty acids
are generated out here
in the cytosol when
they're lipases remove them
from the lipid
droplet, it turns out
we're going to burn
the acetyl-CoA we
get from the breakdown
of the fatty acids.
That acetyl-CoA needs
to be in the matrix
so it has access
to the TCA cycle.
And so we need to get the
fatty acid from the cytosol
inside the mitochondria.
Now, part of this--
remember, our CoA
group that I drew last time
is this giant molecule.
And so acetyl-CoA is not
this little two carbon unit.
It's this big, giant molecule.
And so by generating the
acetyl-CoA in the mitochondria,
we obviate the need
to get this giant CoA
group across the
mitochondrial membranes.
But, of course,
we do need to get
the fatty acid into the
right location as well.
And so the way that
that fatty acid
is transported there is
actually via a system
called the carnitine shuttle.
But there's sort of a little bit
of a roundabout way to do it.
And that is, we
are going to need
to do two things-- get the fatty
acid inside the mitochondria
as well as activate it
with this coenzyme A group.
And it turns out that
the fatty acid is first
activated in the cytosol
by adding the coenzyme A
group to the acid on the end,
very much like acetyl-CoA.
And so here is some generic
chain length fatty acid.
And it turns out that
there's an enzyme called
acyl-CoA synthetase
that is going
to take ATP and adenylate this
acid group on the fatty acid.
And so this is
basically an AMP that's
been used to adenylate
the fatty acid itself.
Now, you'll notice
by doing this,
we generate a pyrophosphate.
And that pyrophosphate
can be turned
into two inorganic phosphates--
same trick we've
seen before that
basically can pull a
reaction that otherwise
would be unfavorable forward.
In this case, it's adding the
CoA group to this fatty acid.
And what happens next is that
CoA comes in and replaces
the AMP such that you generate
this fatty acyl-CoA molecule,
which is basically acetyl-CoA
but with some arbitrary longer
a number of reduced hydrocarbons
in the chain-- so not
a 2-carbon unit, but a fatty
acid-- a many carbon unit
fatty acid with whatever
other properties happen
to be on fatty
acid, where now you
have this fatty acyl-CoA
instead of the fatty acid.
So it turns out this
fatty acyl-CoA then
is subjected to a shuttle
called the carnitine shuttle
to actually get it
into the mitochondria.
And so what is carnitine?
So carnitine is a
small molecule--
looks like this.
So this here is carnitine.
And it turns out that this
hydroxyl group, basically,
is swapped for the CoA
on the fatty acyl-CoA.
And so if this here is
some generic fatty CoA,
you end up with this
molecule, which is
called a fatty acyl carnitine.
So all I've done is take the
CoA off and move the fatty acid
to make this ester here with
the alcohol on the carnitine.
And this fatty acyl
carnitine can now
be transported across the
mitochondrial membrane-- so
from the cytosol to
the mitochondria.
Here we have our
fatty acyl carnitine.
And then that fatty
acyl carnitine
can exchange a CoA
for the carnitine
and regenerate
the fatty acyl-CoA
in the mitochondrial matrix.
This whole process is referred
to as the carnitine shuttle
and is effectively a complex
way to move fatty acyl-CoAs
from the cytosol into
the mitochondria, where
they can be oxidized.
Here's another picture
of it that is maybe
drawn in a different
way because it's
a little bit confusing
as something to describe,
but basically you generate this
fatty acyl-CoA in the cytosol.
And then the fatty
acyl-CoA is exchanged
for a fatty acyl carnitine.
Fatty acyl carnitine
goes into the matrix
and is used to regenerate
the fatty acyl-CoA.
The enzymes that do
this is something
called CPT, or carnitine
palmitoyltransferase.
Write that down-- carnitine,
which is obviously refers
to palmitate as the
common fatty acid,
although CPT will catalyze
many fatty acyl carnitine,
fatty acyl-CoA interconversions.
And so by doing
that interconversion
on the cytosolic side and
the mitochondrial side,
you can use
carnitine as a handle
to transfer fatty acyl-CoAs
from one compartment to another.
Now, once that fatty acyl-CoA
is in the mitochondria,
it can now be oxidized
to acetyl-CoA.
So now, let's discuss
the series of steps
that is referred to as
fatty acid oxidation,
and abbreviated FAO.
And so, of course, we start here
with our generic fatty acyl-CoA
in the matrix of the
mitochondria of some arbitrary
chain length.
And so the first thing
that we're going to do
is oxidize this
carbon-carbon bond--
that is, introduce
a double bond here.
That's an oxidation reaction.
It's exactly the
same reaction that we
saw convert succinate to
fumerate in the TCA cycle.
That reaction used FAD
as an electron acceptor.
So we oxidize that
carbon-carbon bond, FAD
gets reduced to FADH2.
This is carried out by an enzyme
called acyl-CoA dehydrogenase
and generates that intermediate.
Again, now just like
we did in the TCA cycle
when we converted
fumerate into malate,
we added water across
this double bond.
Do exactly the same thing here.
That generates
this intermediate.
Now we can oxidize this
carbon here, this alcohol--
oxidize it to the ketone.
Of course, you know
how to do this.
We've now seen it
a million times.
So that generates
this hydride ion,
which can be transferred to
NAD+, reducing it to NADH.
And now what happens next
is CoA basically breaks
that carbon-carbon bond.
And what are we left with?
We're left with over here
release of a acetyl-CoA group,
which can then go down and be
further oxidized in the TCA
cycle as well as this
fatty acyl-CoA that
is two carbons shorter than
the one we started with.
That can then go back up,
repeat the cycle again
until, if you start with
an even number of carbons,
the last one leaves you with
two acetyl-CoA molecules.
And so per two
carbon units that we
run through this cycle of
fatty acid oxidation, what
we get is we get an
acetyl-CoA that comes out,
we get an FADH2,
and we get an NADH.
Now, of course, if we start
with an unsaturated fatty acid,
we don't have to introduce
a double bond into it,
we don't get the FADH2,
we get less energy
produced from that molecule.
And so if this acetyl-CoA goes
on and enters the TCA cycle
and we fully oxidize it to
CO2, we get three more NADH,
we get another FADH2,
and we get a GTP.
It's written up
there as a reminder.
And so with a fully saturated
per two carbons out,
we basically get four NADHs,
two FADH2s, and a GTP.
And that's a fair amount
of energy, if you will,
released from the oxidation
of this fatty acid
all the way to CO2.
We'll come back to that
accounting in a second.
But first I want to
say, what happens
if you happen to start with
an odd number of carbons.
So I mentioned that most
biological fatty acids
have even numbers of carbons.
But there are odd chain
carbon lengths of fatty acids.
Some bacteria make these.
Sometimes it just happens.
Obviously, if you
do that, you'll
end up at the end with
this molecule, which
is a 3-carbon acetyl-CoA
called propionyl-CoA.
And so cells need
a way to deal with
this 3-carbon propionyl-CoA.
Well, the way they deal with
it is they carboxylic it.
So if we're going to
add a CO2 to a molecule,
how do we do that?
Well, we need a co-factor.
Remember, we did this with the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction.
This was the reaction of biotin.
So we started with bicarbonate.
We phosphorylated
the bicarbonate.
And then that
phosphorylated bicarbonate,
there was biotin in the
active site of the enzyme.
That released the phosphate.
I had enzyme biotin
with a CO2 on it.
And so if we take this
propionyl-CoA here,
which is drawn in the keto
form, and we redraw it
in enol form of
the propionyl-CoA,
we carry out similar
reaction that we saw before.
And now we end up
with this molecule.
So, effectively, adding
the CO2 to this carbon
to the second carbon in.
And that's this molecule, which
is called methyl-malonyl-CoA.
I'm going to redraw
methyl-malonyl-CoA just
to show you how
cells deal with this.
So this is methyl-malonyl-CoA.
I just re-drew it in
a way that there's
some colors on the
different molecules.
What I'm going to
do is I'm basically
going to take this
group and this group
and swap their positions.
And if I do that, I will
end up with this molecule,
which hopefully you recognize
as succinyl-CoA from the TCA
cycle.
Now, the mechanism for
how that swap happens,
I don't have time to go into.
But this complex
intermolecular rearrangement
requires a cofactor.
That cofactor comes
from vitamin B12.
And so here's a
picture of vitamin B12.
You can see by looking
at it why I don't
want to draw that out for you.
It's a cobalt-containing
cofactor-- sometimes referred
to as cobalamin.
If you're interested,
you can look up
the chemistry for how
vitamin B12 helps catalyze
this intermolecular
rearrangement
to go from methyl-malonyl-CoA
to succinyl-CoA.
But the important take home is
that if you have an odd chain
fatty acid, use a
biotin-containing enzyme
to carboxylate propionyl-CoA
to methyl-malonyl-CoA, and then
B12 to rearrange that
methyl-malonyl-CoA
to succinyl-CoA.
And now this can enter the TCA
cycle and be oxidized as well.
So now you have
the details of how
you can start with a fatty
acid and oxidize it to CO2.
Now, I think it's
useful if we compare
the output of what we can get
from glucose oxidation to CO2--
carbohydrate oxidation to CO2--
to what we can get if we
start with a fatty acid
and oxidize it to
CO2 and sort of
illustrate that there
are more calories in fat
than there are in sugar.
And so for this
comparison, we'll
compare glucose, which, of
course, has six carbons in it
to a 6:0 fatty acid--
also six carbons.
And what do we get if we
take this less reduced
versus more reduced molecule
and fully oxidize it to CO2?
Well, if we start with glucose--
so if we take that glucose
and we run glycolysis--
and so take that
glucose and turn it
into two pyruvate
molecules, of course
we get from that two
ATPs and two NADHs.
And then if we take those two
pyruvate molecules and turn
them into two acetyl-CoAs
plus two CO2s--
that's the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction--
we get two more NADHs.
And then if we take
those two acetyl-CoAs
and turn them into
four CO2s, that's
the TSA cycle,
what do we get out?
We get two GTP molecules.
We get two FADH2 molecules from
the succinate dehydrogenase
step.
And we get 2 times 3
equals 6 more NADHs.
And so our total yield is 4
ATP equivalents-- remember,
the GTPs can be
interconverted with ATP--
two FADH2s, and 6,
7, 8, 9, 10 NADHs.
What if we start with
our 6:0 zero fatty acid?
Well, to metabolize it, first
we have to take that fatty acid
and we have to make
our fatty acyl-CoA.
That's going to cost us two ATP.
Why two ATP?
Because remember when we
charge that fatty acetyl-CoA,
which is now erased,
I think-- yes, it is--
we converted an ATP to an AMP.
And so that's two
ATP equivalents
to charge that fatty
acid to a fatty acyl-CoA.
Next, we take that
fatty acyl-CoA
and we turn it into three
acetyl-CoA molecules
via fatty acid oxidation cycle.
That's two trips around to
generate the three acetyl-CoAs.
So that will give us two
FADH2s and two NADHs.
And then once we have
those three acetyl-CoA,
we can turn them into six
CO2s in the TCA cycle.
So that's three
GTPs, three FADH2s.
And 3 times 3 is 9 NADHs for
a total yield of 3 minus 2
is 1 ATP equivalent,
5 FADHs, and 11 NADHs.
Now, I went through
this exercise
because it's not
immediately apparent
that the yield of
fatty acid oxidation
gives you more energy
from full oxidation
than oxidizing the equivalent
carbohydrate, at least
in terms of ATP.
You get four ATPs directly
from full oxidation of glucose,
whereas you only get one
ATP equivalent directly
from the complete oxidation of
this 6-carbon fatty acyl-CoA.
Now, I say this because most
of the energy, if you will,
that's released from
oxidation of fat and sugar
isn't actually
directly producing ATP.
It's actually being used to
charge up this NADH, and NAD+,
or FADH2/FAD ratios in the cell,
which we will see is also a lot
of energy, because those
electrons can be transferred
to oxygen and be used to do
other work down the road.
Now, your book will tell
you that each of these NADHs
or FADH2s are worth on the
order of one to three ATP.
And I guess this kind
of fits intuitively what
you might guess based on the
thermodynamics of the GAPDH
reaction.
So if you go back
to that, remember
our oxidative phosphorylation
we described at GAPDH
roughly generated an ATP.
And so even if we say one ATP
equals an FADH2 or an NADH,
which, of course, there's not
a direct relationship to that,
you can still,
even with that, say
that our fatty acid oxidation--
if we add up all these numbers,
we would get 17, whereas if
we add up all these numbers,
we get 16.
So I guess that says
that there's more
coming from fatty acid oxidation
than from complete glucose
oxidation.
But you probably also learned
in high school or somewhere else
that NADH gives you
more ATP than FADH2.
That's true.
Our goal is to understand
why that's the case.
And so those numbers
will only get better
for fatty acid oxidation
in terms of ATP equivalents
when we can describe how
to do those conversions.
However, to really appreciate
how these electron carriers
equal energy and equal
biological energy,
we really need to
go back and revisit
some concepts in bioenergetics
and thermodynamics
to really understand what
biological energy is.
And that will also
help us understand
mitochondrial oxidative
phosphorylation, which
is really the process that
allows us to interconvert
these electron carriers
and their ability
to transfer electrons to
oxygen as a way to generate
favorably synthesized ATP.
So hopefully, you will remember
from our previous lectures
that for any reaction, any
pathway, any process to occur,
it has to be thermodynamically
favorable-- that is,
delta G has to be less than 0.
And remember, ATP
to ADP was useful
because that reaction
is very favorable.
And so we could couple ATP to
ADP conversion to otherwise
unfavorable reactions.
And that is what allowed
us to have ATP be useful.
And it was useful because delta
G equals delta G naught prime
plus RT times a
log of the products
of the reaction over the
reactants of the reaction.
And so if ADP is a product
in ATP is a reactant,
it was actually
that ATP/ADP ratio
that was providing the
energy, if you will,
to drive the reaction.
This was also, if you
recall, why we described
that oxidation of reduced
carbon because it was favorable,
was able to be coupled
to reactions that
keep this ATP/ADP ratio high, so
that that high ratio could then
support otherwise
unfavorable reactions.
But now, you
hopefully appreciate
that in reality, most of the
energy from carbon oxidation
is not directly captured as ATP.
It's being used to charge
up these other ratios--
NAD/NADH, FADH2/FAD.
And the energetics of doing that
follow exactly the same rules
as ATP or really
any other reaction.
And effectively,
it's the transfer
of electrons that is
favorable or not that
really is going on
here, just like we
discussed for ATP to ADP.
And so we can couple other
reactions to those ratios
as a way to make other
reactions possible.
Now, ultimately it turns
out that these things,
these redox ratios, are more
useful than ATP because these
electron transfers-- favorable
electron transfers-- remember,
biological energy is all about
oxidation and reduction--
can be used to drive ATP.
We'll see that when we described
how OXPHOS in the mitochondria
really works.
But it can be used for
other things as well.
We'll see we can
use it to make heat.
We can do it other work,
like move ions, et cetera.
And so-- we can even
make glucose, right?
gluconeogenesis.
We needed a source of NADH.
And so ultimately, all
biological energy, of course,
has to come from the sun.
And photosynthesis also is
about capturing solar energy
as these oxidation
and reduction pairs.
And so if we appreciate
this, what we realize
is that it's really these
transfers of electrons.
Remember, there's no free
electrons in biology.
And so it's really coupling
oxidation and reduction
reactions that
are favorable that
ends up being how
bioenergetics largely works.
Now, I like to be
explicit about this
because sometimes
people get confused
by oxidation and reduction
reactions and focus on charge.
And I just want to point
out oxidation and reduction
reactions are really
moving electrons.
And this is
irrelevant of charge.
So I add an electron to
an uncharged molecule,
I get a negatively
charged molecule.
Add it to a positively
charged molecule,
get a neutral molecule.
Add it to a more positively
charged molecule,
now have a positively
charged molecule.
It's adding these electrons.
Each of these are
reduction reactions.
In that direction, they
would be oxidation reactions.
And so NAD+ plus 2
electrons going to NADH,
FAD plus 2 electrons
going to FADH2--
all reductions in
this direction, all
oxidations in that direction.
Now, because there's
not free electrons,
these reactions have
to happen in pairs.
And so if we consider
a pair, here's
lactate interconversion
with pyruvate.
So alcohol and lactate to
the ketone and pyruvate--
this direction is an oxidation.
That means the electrons
have to go somewhere--
NAD+ to NADH.
This is a reduction.
If we go from pyruvate to
lactate, that's a reduction.
We can reoxidize
NADH back to NAD+.
Of course, you'll remember
from glycolysis fermentation,
this inner conversion
is catalyzed by LDH.
And effectively, if you're going
to use lactate for energy--
so we oxidize the
lactate, generate NADH.
If we're going to use
it for fermentation,
we produce lactate, reoxidize
the NADH back to NAD+.
How does LDH know which
direction to go in?
How does any
reaction, any pathway
know which direction to go in?
Its delta G.
Delta G-- well, it's delta
G naught prime plus RT times
the log of, in this case, the
pyruvate lactate ratio times
the NADH/NAD+ ratio.
And so how oxidized or reduced
NAD+ to NADH is will determine
how oxidized and reduced the
pyruvate lactate ratio is.
In other words, this must
be true for absolutely
any redox pair.
And in general, remember
carbon oxidation is favorable.
And that's because
oxidizing carbon
to give those electrons
to something downstream,
ultimately oxygen, is favorable.
That's really what's driving
each of these pathways.
Now, how favorable
any of this is,
of course, can be quantified?
And if we want to know
this for this redox pair
or any redox pair,
of course, this
is related to some
equilibrium constant.
And we've already discussed
that we can have this term delta
G naught prime that is relevant
to the equilibrium constant.
But it's still, because delta
G determines what happens,
it's still that
equilibrium constant
plus the ratios of the reactants
and products that will really
determine if the
reaction happens.
However, it turns out it's
useful to think about--
when electrons can go
to donated or accepted
in lots of different
reactions, it's
useful to come up
with a term that
helps us know what
is the propensity
of an individual pair
to accept or donate
an electron in either direction.
And we have a term for this.
It's denoted E naught prime,
which is the standard reduction
potential that
basically describes
for a pair of molecules--
NADH+, NADH, pyruvate,
and lactate--
in an oxidation or
reduction reaction,
how likely is it to
give up its electrons
in one direction or the other.
And so the units
of this is volts.
And the standard
reduction potential
can be calculated as follows.
And of course, it's related
to the equilibrium constant
of a reaction.
And so the equilibrium
constant overreaction,
delta G naught prime-- related
to the equilibrium constant--
is this formula.
N is the number of
electrons transferred,
F is the Faraday constant,
and delta E naught prime
is the change in
standard reduction
potential from electron donation
from one pair to the next pair.
So if we use our lactate
pyruvate example,
we have lactate going to
pyruvate plus 2 electrons.
So that's the electron donor.
It's being oxidized.
And then you have NAD+ plus
the electrons going to NADH.
It's being reduced-- two
electrons, of course--
it's being reduced.
And so this has a standard
reduction potential.
This half reaction has a
standard reduction potential.
And so the difference between
these standard reduction
potentials--
that is, who receives
the electrons, delta E
naught primed 2 minus
delta E naught prime 1
gives us this change in standard
reduction potential, which
I can plug into
this formula, which
is related to the equilibrium
constant and tells me
which direction of
electron transfer
is going to be favored,
at least at equilibrium.
And so if this number is
related to equilibrium,
there's a negative here.
And so if this term is
positive, delta G naught prime
will be negative.
And that means that
electron transfer
will be favored at equilibrium.
If this number is
negative, that means
the reverse electron transfer
will be favored at equilibrium.
And so it stands to reason
then that electron transfer
from smaller standard reduction
potential to larger standard
reduction potentials
will be favored.
Hopefully that makes sense--
so smaller to larger.
Now, that could be
more negative to less
negative, negative to positive,
positive to more positive.
As long as that
delta is positive,
electron transfer
will be favored.
Now, of course, the
ratios still matter.
But this standard
reduction potential
is useful because
it can help us know
which direction transfer wants
to occur between any redox
pairs at equilibrium.
And so recognizing
this, you must
know that carbon oxidation
electron transfer in general
is going to be favored
to NAD to make NADH.
And in general, that
NADH electron transfer
is going to be
favored to oxygen.
And it's coupling those
favorable electron transfers
that ultimately is
allowing the system
to use oxidation and
reduction reactions to drive
these various pathways.
And that energy release
from these electron transfer
reactions can be used to
make ATP and do other work,
as we will talk about in great
detail in the next lecture.